[موسيقى]
تركيا ومصر نحو فتح صفحه جديده وقمه
مرتقبه بين السيسي
مخاطر حرب اهليه في اسرائيل
يستشعرها الجميع الا نتنياه وحكومته
لائحه الاتهامات ضد ترامب تتسع ويحدد
بنفسه الزمان ومكان اعتقاله
الوسائط المتعدده اصدار رابع ثوري من تشاد
الذكاء الاصطناعي ساحه حرب محترمه بين
امريكا والصين
[موسيقى]
على ارضيه ما تراها مصر صلبه تعود
العلاقات مع تركيا بعد احد عشر عاما من
الانقطاع والقطيعه حتى اقدموا وزير
الخارجيه التركيه في القاهره لتوضع خطوط
عريضه لعوده ثنائيه تستهل برفع التمثيل
الدبلوماسي بين البلدين والاتفاق على
تسميه سفراء جدد خلال العام الحالي مصادر
العربيه اكدت ان قمه مصريه تركيه ستجمع في
النصف الثاني من العام بين الرئيسين عبد
الفتاح السيسي ورجب طيب اردوغان ضمن جدول
زمني تم الاتفاق عليه
[موسيقى]
في خط زمنيا متسارع لردم الهوى او هكذا
عقد العزم على عوده العلاقات المصريه
التركيه
دشنت المصافحه الشهيره للرئيسين السيسي
واردغان في نوفمبر الماضي بدايه مرحله
جديده على هامشي افتتاح مونديال قطر 45
دقيقه من الحديث بحسب اردوغان اذنت لما
سياتي بعدها السابع والعشرون من فبراير
دبلوماسيه الزلزال غير المتوقع عجلت خطوات
القاهره نحو انقره اقتضت زياره وزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري لتسليم شحنه
مساعدات اغاثيه مصريه لتركيا وسبقها اتصال
تضامن رئاسي مصري وزير الخارجيه التركيه
اليوم يبدا ما اقرته بلاده في الثامن
والعشرين من نوفمبر على لسانه باعاده
علاقات مصر وتركيا الدبلوماسيه بالكامل في
الاشهر المقبله شاوش شغله في القاهره
اليوم ومن القاهره يقول
نشكر الحكومه المصريه على المساعدات التي
قدمتها في هذه الفتره ما يعبر عن التضامن
بين البلدين فان العلاقه بين تركيا ومصر
هي علاقه تاريخيه وثقافه مشتركه لذلك نود
ان نقوي هذه العلاقه بيننا الامر الذي
يحتاج الى مساعده من الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي والرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ونحن نعمل
على تسهيل عقد لقاء بينهما
هناك خطوه سابقه اقدم من الزيارتين
والمصافحه مهدت ارضيه الاصلاح والعوده او
عكست النوايا على الاقل في
2021 عقد البلدان السلسله جولات تشاوريه
واستكشافيه ضمت مسؤولين دبلوماسيين لم
تسفر اي منها عن تقدم يدرك الجانبان عمق
الخلافات ولم تاتي الخطوه نحو التطبيع
الكامل الان الا بعد تفاهمات مرضيه مشروطه
لم تناقش علنا لكن مصادر العربيه اكدت ان
التفاهمات التي تبدا من ليبيا تجاوبت معها
انقره مصر متمسكه بضروره توحيد المؤسسات
الليبيه ودعم اقامه الانتخابات في موعدها
وضروره تفكيك الميليشيات المسلحه وهي
مطالب اكدت بموجبها تركيا على اتخاذ
الخطوات المناسبه لتتماشى مع تطوير
العلاقات مع مصر البلدان المتشاركان لشرق
البحر المتوسط المتنازع على موارده من
الطاقه والغاز الطبيعي خصوصا طالبت مصر
بضروره طلبه تركيا عفوا بضروره وجود
تفاهمات وتشاورات حول ملفات ترسيم الحدود
والغاز مجدده طلبها بالتواجد في منتدى
غازي شرق المتوسط وفي هذا الملف عقد كثيره
تحكمها اتفاقيه يعتبرها المجتمع الدولي
غير قانونيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
احد عشر اسبوعا على تولي نتنياهو رئاسه
وزراء اسرائيل وبحلول هذه المرحله تقريبا
كان معظم القاده الاسرائيليين الجدد منذ
سبعينيات القرن الماضي قد زاروا الولايات
المتحده او التقوا برئيسها لكن معنى هذه
المره الامر مختلف لا دعوه من البيت
الابيض بعد واشنطن رفضت التعليق على الامر
وهذا ما يدل على ان الولايات المتحده
حاليا تنظر الى حكومه نتنياهو على انها
مزعجه وغير مرحب بها على اجنده الاداره
بحسب صحيفتها الاسرائيليه
التقارير الصحفيه الامريكيه والاسرائيليه
تشير الى تحفظ امريكي على برنامج تغيير
القضاء الذي تقترحه حكومه نتنياهو لكن
اداره بايدن تفضل المحادثات الهادئه على
الانتقادات العالميه وفق مسؤولا كبير في
الخارجيات الامريكيه وان حملت التصريحات
العلنيه انتقادات
عندما تتطلع الى اجراء تغييرات كبيره
الاصلاحات الرئيسيه في قوانينك في مؤسستك
ربما يكون الاجماع هو الاكثر اهميه بهذا
الخصوص والتاكد من ذلك ليس امرا مقبولا
فقط بل سيستمر وهي مساله دائمه
الغضب والامريكيه برز في زياره وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
بحسب موقعي ولا اشار الى ان مسؤلي
الخارجيه الامريكيه قالوا قبل الزياره في
محادثات انهم سيكونون سعداء اذا لم يكن
سموتريتش بزياره واشنطن الذي دعا الى محو
بلده حوار الفلسطينيه وان قام بالزياره لم
يلتقي به اي مسؤولا امريكي رسمي لكن هل
يمكن ان يتوسع الامر لدول اكثر وان يصل
الامر لمقاطعه نتنياهو بنفسه رابطه حقوق
الانسان في فرنسا انتقدت زياره سموتريتش
المقرره غدا الى فرنسا واكدت انه غير مرحب
به في باريس اما قاده التظاهرات في
اسرائيل المحتجين على خطط تغيير القضاء
وعلى رفض نتنياهو مقترح الرئيس للوساطه
والحل توجهوا بنداء الى زعماء العالم ككل
قاطع نتنياهو ووزرائه
الى حفيد حفيدي سلام كيف حال شعب اسرائيل
هل يوجد شيء اسمه اسرائيل تحذير خطر في
صحيفه يدعو تحرنوت من الكاتب فليور بن
عامي الذي كتب رساله تخيليات اكد فيها ان
الحرب الاهليه في اسرائيل اقرب من اي وقت
مضى وجهه نظر هي المسيطره في اسرائيل
حاليا ورئيس معهد سياسه الشعب
اليهوديا
سار على نفس الخط اسرائيل اليوم اقرب الى
الحرب الاهليه مقارنه بالوقت الذي اعقب
مقتل اسحاق رابين عام
1995 السؤال هل ما يحدث في اسرائيل هو
وليد اللحظه يجيب بمايكل الكاتب في
صحيفتها ما يحدث اليوم ما هو الا تتويج ل
55 عاما من الادمان على الشر والنهب
والاستبداد والعنف التحذير من اندلاع حرب
اهليه امتدا الى عدد من كبار الضباط بعضهم
في الخدمه وبعضهم الاخر في الاحتياط تكتمل
التحذيرات لرئيس البلا
اريد ان اخبركم بشيء من القلب في هذه
الاسابيع قابلت الاف المواطنين افضل
مواطني البلد وطنيين حقيقيين من جميع
جوانب النزاع في اسوا كوابيس لم اكن اعتقد
انني ساسمع كلمات من هذه القبيل كلمات
مخيفه حقا يقول البعض من يعتقد ان حربا
حقيقيه بين الاشقاء هي حد لن نصل اليه لا
يعرف شيئا
اذا
هناك هيرا من المجتمع الاسرائيلي بصعوبه
الاوضاع والشواهد على ذلك كثيره اولها
الاحتجاجات المستمره ضد الحكومه كما ذكرنا
مشاريع القوانين التي تريدها حكومه
نتنياهو تثير غضب الشارع لانها ستغير
العلاقه بين الحكومه الجهه التنفيذيه
والسلطه القضائيه
سترفض الحكومه ستفرض الحكومه رايها في
تشكيل المحكمه العليا وتتقلص صلاحياتها في
الاعتراض على التشريعات التي تقرها
الاغلبيه في الكنيست النتيجه منحوله
امكانيه الهروب من اي محاكمه قضائيه
لوقائع الفساد المتهم بها واعطائه الحق في
منح مناصب وزاريه
لمتهمين بالفساد اخرين في التحالف الحكومي
من دون اي اعتراض من السلطه القضائيه
وتجاوز احكامها السابقه بشان هؤلاء كما
حدث مع الوزير ارياد راعي
التظاهرات التي انطلقت في الشوارع
الاسرائيليه ضد هذه الخطط اظهرت مدى
الانقسام الحاد في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
شهدت مشاركه متصاعده من كبار ضباط
الاحتياط مثلا هناك ضابطان على الاستيلاء
على دبابه اسرائيليه غير مستخدمه في
الجولان اللقاء عليها بيانا رافضا
للاصلاحات القضائيه ساره بها في الطرقات
ودعيا الناس لي توقيع للتوقيع عليها
التجاوب كان كبيرا حتى قبض عليهما لكن
الامر تطور من اثنين الى
750 ضابطا من القوات الجويه والقوات
الخاصه
والاستخباراتيه واكدوا عدم حضورهم للخدمه
بدءا من يوم غد يوم الاحد اعتراضا على خطط
الحكومه التي تخرب امن الدوله
وديمقراطيتها بحسب ما قاله الانقسام الحاد
داخل الاجهزه الامنيه ظهر في تصريحات
المفوض العام للشرطه الاسرائيليه كوبي
الشرطه غير سياسيه وستتصرف وفقا للقانون
الرساله مبطنه لوزير الامن القومي اتمار
المتهم التورط المفرط في تعليمات للشرطه
اثناء التظاهرات
[موسيقى]
والنار
كل هذه الامور قد تقود اسرائيل لحرب اهليه
محتمله لكن تداعياتها بدات في الظهور
اقتصاديا هناك حاله هروب للاموال من
البنوك الاسرائيليه بمعدلات فقط عشر مرات
المعدل المعتاد ولذلك جاء اجتماع وزير
الماليه مع رؤساء البنوك الذين عبروا عن
تخوفهم من مخاطر هروب الاموال وعلى مكانه
البنوك الاسرائيليه في الاسواق الخارجيه
هذه المخاطر التي يعبر عنها رؤساء البنوك
قائمه على ادله ومنها ايقاف مجموعه شركات
كبرى تعمل في المجال الالكتروني وتحويل
مليارين ومئتي مليون دولار من عملياتها
الخارجيه الى الداخل كما نقلت 50 شركه
استثماراتها الى خارج اسرائيل ومنها 37
شركه تعمل في مجال التكنولوجيا كل هذا ادى
الى تحذير الاقتصاديين من تراجع تصنيف
الائتماني لاسرائيل وتراجع الاستثمارات
الخارجيه لكن بماذا يرد وزير الماليه على
هذه المخاطر انكرها واصر على ان الاصلاحات
المنتظره سوف تتجاوز كل هذه الامور
انقسام الحاج في الوسط الاسرائيلي بين
مؤيد للتعديلات القضائيه ومعارض لها لقد
تخطى الصراع البعد السياسي ولم يعد يقتصر
فقط على معسكر اليمين واليسار في الحكومه
ان منطقه تدريجيا الى الشارع الاسرائيلي
عشرات الالاف يتظاهرون يوميا ومئات الالاف
اسبوعيا تتقدمها من نخب العسكريه والمدنيه
ورجال الاقتصاد ومصطلح حرب اهليه بات يطرح
على الطاوله لاول مره بشكل غير مسبوق منذ
اقامه اسرائيل
وتحذيرات من كبار القاده والمسؤولين
فحواها ان لم يقم نتنياهو بتهدئه الاوضاع
وايجاد حلول بديله للتعديلات القضائيه من
غير المستبعد ان تخرج الامور عن السيطره
وقد قال نحو 60% من الاسرائيليين في
استطلاعات للراي ان سيناريو نشوب حرب
اهليه بات واقعيا
للمزيد ينضم الينا من القدس استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه الدكتور مهير
مصري اهلا بك اذا الجميع في اسرائيل
يستشعر خطر الحرب الاهليه الرئيس
الاسرائيلي شدد اللهجه يوم الاربعاء قال
من يظن اننا لن نصل الى الحرب الاهليه فهو
لا يفهم هناك ايضا تصريحات لجانس وايضا
هناك المؤرخين والكتاب الذين يحذرون من
هذه النقطه هي السنه طبعا التوقع الى
تطورات على الارض لماذا لا يستشعر نتنياهو
هذا الخطر حتى الان
الاستضافه كريمه تحياتي لك ولجميع
المشاهدين لا شكر في انه نتنياهو اليوم
اصبح في عزله هو وحكومته وهو باتت في صدام
لا مع المعارضه ليس مع الشارع وانما مع
الدوله اصبحت اليوم الحكومه في صدام مع
الدوله في صدام مع اجهزه الدوله القضاء
الشرطه الجيش
وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان هناك طوق نجاه واحد
ووحيد امام الحكومه وهو مبادره الرئيس
حتى هذه اللحظه لم تقبل بها الحكومه ولكن
يبدو وكانه بدت عمليه تفاوض حيث انه بدات
تناقش او بدا يناقش محتوى هذه المبادره من
قبل بعض اعضاء كنيسه المحسوبين على
الاغلبيه وبالتالي اعتقد انه هذا هو سبيل
الوحيد ولكن في غياب
مع
المعارضه
تحت
قيمه الرئاسه انا اعتقد انه لن يكون هناك
مخرج من هذه الازمه التي لم تعد ازمه
سياسيه بل اصبحت اليوم ازمه دستوريه
نعم وايضا مع هذه التوترات تظهر ايضا هذه
الازمه بين الشرطه واثمار بن كثير وايضا
هناك مواجهات وقعت اليوم بين مناصريه
والمناهضين لاثمار الى اين ياخذ هذا الامر
الوضع في الشارع
نعم في مره اخرى في سياق الازمه الدستوريه
حيث انهما الحكومه تدافع باستماته عن
مشروع قانون غير دستوري الحكومه
تتبنى مشروع قانون وناهض للدستور وناهض
للنظام الدستوري وفقا
راي المحكمه الدستوريه العليا الا وهي
المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل
وقد لا يوقع الرئيس بمناسبه في نهايه
المطاف على مشروع القانون
والشيء الذي سوف يمثل سابقا في تاريخ
اسرائيل
تعرضنا اعتقد انه يجب هنا ان نذكر بانه
للمره الاولى كذلك
واقعه خطيره للغايه وقعت قبل اسبوع وهو
انه وزير التي ذكرت اسمه وزير
الامن الداخلي اي وزير الشرطه
قد اقال
رئيس شرطه تل ابيب ولكن وبدون ان قرار
الاقاله يكون يحتوي على الشروط المتوافره
والمتشكومه والمستشاره القضائيه الحكومه
بالاحرى رفضت هذا القرار وبالتالي ظل في
منصبه ولكن تصوري لو كان لو لو كانت
الشرطه قد اصرت ان تطيع وزير الشرطه
وبعكس راي القضاء وبالتالي هناك قرارات
متناقضه اليوم تاتي قناه من الحكومه
قرارات غير دستوريه ومن ناحيه اخرى القضاء
يعرقلها وبالتالي انه كل هذا مره اخرى
يعبر عن وجود ازمه دستوريه
ومرحله اليوم دخلت لسيف مرحله صدام مباشر
بين السلطه التنفيذيه اي المتماثله
بالحكومه بالاغلبيه بالائتلاف الحاكم من
ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى ليس المعارضه وانما
مؤسسات الدوله نعم من القدس استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه دكتور مائير
المصري شكرا لك
الجمهوريون منقسمون والتوم يلجا للشارع
مجددا في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
سيتم اعتقالي يوم الثلاثاء المقبل في
نيويورك اخرجوا للشوارع من اجل الاحتجاج
توقعا غريب من الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
على منصته سوشل تروت لكن ما القصه التي قد
تمنعه من الترشح للرئاسه امر يعود لما قبل
انتخابات 2016 المزاعم خاصه بشان دفع
مايكل
مبلغا ماليا مبلغا ماليا لممثله اباحيه
مقابل صمتها عن تلك العلاقه المزعومه
بينهما بحسب فوكس نيوز عقد مكتب المدعي
العام في منهات اجتماعا مع سلطات انفاذ
القانون قبل توجيه لائحه اتهام المحتمله
الاسبوع المقبل
يقفان على نفس الارضيه يؤمنان بذات
التوجهات تقريبا بل دعم احدهما الاخر
لكنهما ليس على وفاق الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب وحاكم فلوريدا
اوكرانيا ليست اولويه للولايات المتحده
الاولويه هي لحمايه الحدود الجنوبيه
مواجهه الصين وتعزيز الجيش الامريكي كلمات
قالها قبل ايام ديسانتس لقناه
تصريحنا اعتبرته الاول اخطاء حاكم فلوريدا
وبالمناسبه للوهله تظن انها تصريحات ترامب
الانتقاد دعمي اداره بايدن لاوكرانيا هل
تطابق التصريحات ياتي في مجال الصدفه
يرى ان دي سانتوس يسير على خطاه يتابع كل
ما يقوله هو يريد كل ما يريده من المتوقع
ان يترشح الانتخابات الرئاسه في 2024
ينافس ترامب ويريد ان يرشحه الجمهوريون
امر حذره منه ترامب سابقا بل وابدى ندمه
على دعم ديسانتوس في انتخابات 2018 والتي
اوصلته الى منصب حاكم ولايه فلوريدا
فلوريدا التي تفضل ترامب على حاكمها بحسب
استطلاع رايا لكليه
الحقيقه ان هذا الصراع الكلامي بين
ديسانتوس واترام يظهر يظهر مدى انقسام
الحزب الجمهوري وهو مقبل على اختيار مرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسه في
2024 امر لاحظه المتابعون لتجمع تيار
المحافظين في الحزب الج في مؤتمره السنوي
قبل ايام لما يحضر نائب ترامب السابق مايك
بنس بل واحجم التابعون له عن تخصيص فقرات
لقاده اخرين اكثر اعتدالا في الحزب
لمخاطبه الحضور حضرت طبعا وخاطب الحضور
لمده تسعين دقيقه بل وحصل على تاييد بنحو
62% في استطلاع اجراه المؤتمر لكن بعض
المناويين له حضروا لقاء اخر تزامن مع
المؤتمر نادي التنميه لقاء ترعه ترعه
منظمه معنيه بشان الاقتصادي للمحافظين
ايضا وهذا اللقاء ايد خلال الانتخابات
الرئاسيه السابقه ترشيحه لكنه هذا العام
لم يدعو ترامب للقاء
رغم ان دونالد ترامب ما زال يحظى بتاييد
واسع لدى قاعده الحزب الجمهوري ويتقدم على
باقي المرشحين او المرشحين المحتملين حسب
معظم استطلاعات الراي فان العديده من قاده
الحزب لا يرغبون بان يكون مرشحهم للرئاسه
هؤلاء كانوا في مرمى نيراني هجمات ترامب
خلال المؤتمر السنوي الاخير للمحافظين
الامريكيين الذي شهد حضورا قويا لمؤيديه
اخره هجمات ترامب واعنفها كانت ضد حاكم
فلوريدا الذي ينظر اليه كاخطر منافسيه حيث
اعرب عن دمه لتاييده ووصفه بانه غير مخلص
بعض الاخلاص الترامب يعني عدم ترشحي احد
اخر من الحزب وهذا ما لم يحدث بعد اعلان
نكهه لترشحها واحتمال اعلاني
جميعهم كانوا من موظفي ادارته وهو يعتبر
انه صاحب فضل عليهم هذا عدا عن انتهاء شهر
العسل منذ سنوات بينه وبين وسائل اعلام
كانت مؤيده له مثل
بالحديث عن الانقسام فهناك تيار كبير كان
يدعم ترامب وتخلى عن دعمه ما يزيد من
الشرخ داخل الحزب ماركه ترامب المميزه قد
تضررت بحسب وصف موقع
المدعي العام السابق بالبار كريستي
المقربه من ترامبو ستيفن غراشام السكرتيره
الصحفيه للبيت الابيض التي استقالت بعد
اعمال الشغب في الكابتل في 2020 وهناك
ايضا
نائب الرئيس السابق الذي وصف ما قاله
ترامب حول احداث الكابيتول بالكلمات
المتهوره ووزير الخارجيه السابق
كلاهما ربما يترشحان اصلا للرئاسه بل حتى
وسائل الاعلام صحيفه التي انتقدها ترامب
بعد ان نشرت ملفا كاملا عن خصمه حاليا
ديسانس كمرشح محتمل للرئاسه فوكس نيوز هي
الاخرى التي بالمناسبه غابت عن مؤتمر
المحافظين الذي تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل
صاحبها
يؤمن بان الشبكه ارتكبت خطا في تبنيها
سرديه ترامب بشان حدوث تزوير في سجلات
الناخبين
[موسيقى]
رمضان نائب جمهوري سابق واستاذ علوم سياسه
في جامعه جورج ميسون اهلا بك اذا سابدا
معك من الاكثر سخونه تصريحات ترامب بانه
سيتم اعتقاله يوم الثلاثاء حدد المكان
والزمان ودعا لخروج يعني انصاره
للاحتجاجات في اي اطار نضع هذه التصريحات
الان
شكرا للاستضافه نضعها باطار جنون العظمه
للكرامب ترامب يرى نفسه
الملك على الحزب الجمهوري والملك في
السياسه الامريكيه ويرى انه اعلى من
القانون وانه لا يجب ان يكون هنالك اي
مسؤوليه عليه على ما فعله لذلك نضعها في
اطار جنون العظمه في اطار عدم المسؤوليات
في اطار عدم
اللعبه الديمقراطيه وهذا ما جرت رمب اليه
الحزب الجمهوري خلال الست سنين السابقين
وهذا ما جر ترامب اليه السياسه الامريكيه
بشكل عام ويامل معظم
السياسيين
القدامى اللي هن معظمهم عم نحكي عن
الجمهوريين السياسيين القدامى الذين كانوا
مسؤولين في الحزب ما قبل ترامب وما زالوا
في النشطات سياسيين يعملون اليوم ان
يتخلوا عن ترامب وان تنتهي هذه المرحله
الترامبيه المجنونه التي اوصلت الحزب الى
ما هو عليه اليوم ولكن
هذا تامل وليس في الحقيقه لا يزال ترامب
يسيطر على حوالي اربعين في المئه من
النشطاء في الحزب الجمهوري
وهؤلاء الاربعون او الاربعين
يلعب
ولكن يعني لوائح الاتهام لترامب كثيره
هناك تخلي من الحزب الجمهوري ولكن ايضا
بخصوص هذه القضيه تحديدا يعني على سبيل
المثال ماسك يقول ان لو تم اعتقال ترامب
بهذه القضيه فسيفوز بشكل ساحق في
الانتخابات كيف ستؤثر هذه القضيه على ترشح
ترامب
لا اول شيء ليست اعتقال بل توقيف
عندما يكون هنالك جرم اتهام جرمي يتم
توقيف الشخص هو ثم ثم
يتركه بيطلع على بيته بمقابل
فلوس مصاري او
[موسيقى]
جرانتي
فاذا هو توقيف وليس اعتقال وهذا مهم جدا
عندما نفرق ما بين اثنين هل سيؤثر ذلك على
انتخابه لا لن يؤثر ذلك هنالك 40% من
الحزب الجمهوري يدعمون ترامب
على العمل يدعمونه ان كان موقوفا او ليس
موقوفا لن يتغير هذا الرقم ولن يزيد دعمه
ولن يكون لذلك سيكون الموضوع موضوع هل
سيقتدر اي مرشح اخر جمهوري ان يحصل على
الستين في الميه الباقيين او سيكون هنالك
عشر مرشحين للي عم يتبروا 60% الباقيين
متل ما صار اول مره ويكون ترامب في ربح
الترشيح الجمهوري بالاربعين بالميه الذين
يدعمون لكن هناك ايضا دور للاعلام دكتور
ديفيد لا يمكن انكاره ان كانت الان في
يعني تتخلى عن ترامب نحن نعلم كم دعمت
ترامب في فتره انتخابه في 2016 فكيف سيكون
وضعه مع الاعلام هل سيؤثر ذلك على حظوظه
في الترشح مجددا
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا لك معنا من فرجينيا دكتور
اديبه رمضان نائب جمهوري سابق واستاذ علوم
السياسيه في جامعات جورج ميسون
[موسيقى]
امام الجيش الصيني الذي بات يمتلك اضخم
اسطول بحري في العالم وفي المكان الذي
يغيب فيه ظل امريكا تنين صيني بحري بقدره
صناعيه رهيبه تطورا اقلق الحلفاء والنيتو
لم ينجح في الامتداد الى المحيط الهادئ
بين الازمه والحل واشنطن لم تضيع الكثير
من الوقت ولد كبيرا في 2021 اوكوس حلف
بريطاني امريكي استرالي انضمامه استراليا
رافقته قرارات صعبه راحت ضحيتها فرنسا
التي خسرت صفقه غواصات مع استراليا بقيمه
سبعه 37 مليار دولار
وصلها وصفها بطعامه حليف
صفقه الغواصات التي تمت قبل ايام تلتزم
واشنطن بموجبها بالنقل تكنولوجيا نوويه
لبلد غير نووي هذا يحدث لاول مره في
التاريخ ورغم انها وصفت القرار بمجرد
تصدير طاقه نوويه الا انا انشاء بنيه
تحتيه مماثله في استراليا يقلق الصين
مشكله اخرى تؤرق بكين ما بات يجمع الثلاثي
فوق مبادئ من امريكا الى استراليا سيتم
مشاركه التكنولوجيا الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه
والذكاء الاصطناعي ووسائل الحرب
الالكترونيه صفقه غواصات تحولت الى بوادر
سباق تسلح لكن استراليا ليست الوحيده
المستفيده من الصفقه
صفقه الغواصات النوويه التي ابرمتها
بريطانيا مع الولايات المتحده واستراليا
ضمن تحالف اوكس لن تكون في مصلحه استراليا
فقط حيث ستتيح الصفقه تحديد اسطول
بريطانيا من الغواصات النوويه ليصل الى
تسعه عشره غواصه بدلا من سبع غواصات حاليا
وسيشرع الاتفاق من الان في تدريب
الاستراليين على استخدام الغواصات وتطوير
قدراتهم البحريه على ان ترسل بريطانيا
غواصه واحده الى استراليا عام
2027 اما الغواصات الجديده التي ستكون
بتصميم بريطاني وتكنولوجيا الدفاعيه
امريكيه فسيبدا تطويرها اواخر هذا العقد
على ان تصنع بريطانيا اول غواصه اواخر
العقد الثالث من هذا القرن وتعد الصفقه
مكسبا سياسيا لسوناك الذي اثار حفيظه نواب
من حزبه بعد تحذيره في وقت سابق من خطط
الصين دون ان يصنفها على انها تهديد للامن
القومي
عكس بريطانيا واستراليا لم تتحصل بكين على
غواصاتها كهديه تطويرها كان مشروعا وطنيا
صرح موت بان بلاده مصممه على بناء غواصه
نوويه ولو بعد الف عام 50 عاما مرت على
الغواصه النوويه الصينيه الاولى وطريق
استراليا الذي بدا اليوم لن يكون اكثر من
طريق الصينيين والدليل في بنود الاتفاق
ستتسلم استراليا اول ثلاث غواصات عام 2030
بينما تطمح بريطانيا لبناء اول غواصه
نوويه محليه عام 2040 برنامجا يمتد لعقود
وهنا تبرز قوه الصين وذلك بقدرتها على
انجاز المشاريع في زمن قياسي عقبه اخرى
اقتصاديه هذه المره استراليا تحتاج انفاق
عشره مليارات دولار سنويا لتمويل المشروع
بينما خصصت لندن 6 مليارات سنويا
اقتصاديه واحده قد تنسف المشروع كل هذا
واستراليا لن تتمكن من صنع غواصاتها
الاولى قبل
2040 مشروع مرهون باراده حكومات الحلفاء
المتعاقبه والوضع في الصين مغاير نظامها
يمتاز باستقرار طويل الامد وفره الاموال
والاراده السياسيه لا تكفيان للنجاح
المشروع يحتاج تنسيق فعالا وتبادلا امنا
للمعلومات اضافه الى بنيه تحتيه نوويه هي
غائبه حاليا في استراليا
[موسيقى]
ميزانيات ماء ضخمه وفي النهايه نجاح
المشروع لن يدر على استراليا اكثر من
اثنتين عشره غواصه عدد زهيد مقارنه بسبع
وسبعين غواصه تمتلكها الصين فما الذي يقلق
الغواصات الاستراليه قادر على تحقيق
التوازن في منطقه المحيط الهادئ وتوازن
التكنولوجي وليس كميا ميدان الصراع في
المحيط الهادئ تقدر المسافات فيه بالاف
الكيلومترات قاعده الغواصات الاستراليه في
مثلا تبعد عن قاعده هاينان الصينيه
للغواصات باكثر من 11 الف كيلو متر مسافه
تقطعها الغواصات خلال الثلاثه اسابيع على
الاقل وهنا الفرق غواصه الديزل القادره
على البقاء تحت الماء اسبوعا واحدا فقط
عكس الغواصه النوويه التي تضطر للعوده الى
مينائها مره كل ثلاث سنوات ليس للتزود
بالوقود للتزود بغذاء للطاقه الغواصات
النوويه ايضا لا تخلو من العيوب المفاعل
يحتاج للتبريد باستمرار حتى في حاله
التوقف وتصريف مياه التبريد الساخنه
فالمياه الساخنه تترك بصمه تتعرف عليها
المقاتلات المضاده
اذا مشاهدينا كيف يفهم تشات جي بي تي ما
نكتبها الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
قضيه عمران خان هي الشغل الشاغل في
باكستان الان كما نتابع شرطه مكافحه الشغب
حاولت دخول منزل الرئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني السابق بعد مغادرته لاسلام
اباد للمثول امام المحكمه بشان قضايا فساد
ربما كان الدخول بشكل طبيعي صعبا ليلجا
رجال الشرطه كما نشاهد الى الالات الثقيله
لدخول المقر
الى ملف اخر الصراع على ضروره التكنولوجيا
وخطورتها الامر ليس جديدا ليس جديدا ابدا
ففي بريطانيا استخدامه الالات في المصانع
في القرن التاسع عشر كان معضله مناهضوا
الثوره الصناعيه اصحاب الحرف اليدويه
تحولوا حينها الى عصابات تقتحم المصانع
وتدمر الالات استخدام الاله الحاسبه مثلا
مثل تحديا لمدرسي الرياضيات في ولايه
واشنطن في
1986 اخرجهم استخدام الطلاب لها في
تظاهرات غاضبه ترفض المساس بالقدره
الحسابيه البشريه
علمنا منذ الخمسينات يعيش ثوره تكنولوجيه
جديده بين الانقسام حولها والاجماع عليها
من فريقين عالميين الحقيقه واحده وهي ان
قافله الطفره
بلا مكابح الذكاء الاصطناعي بات ذكيا جدا
وتحديدا منذ نوفمبر 2022 حين اعلنت شركه
اوبن اي عن تشاتشي ولمن فاتته مميزات هذا
الاختراع فهو ببساطه نظام رد تلقائي على
كل ما يمكن ان نبحث عنه للمعرفه هو ليس
كنظام رسائل خدمه العملاء المسجله
بالتاكيد الامر اعقد على بساطه استخدامه
تجربه عمليات تشرح كل شيء لو طلبنا من
مقاله حول ذوبان الجليد في القطب الشمالي
ستظهر هذه الاجابه
يمكننا ايضا ان نطلب منه ان يجيبنا كموظف
موارد بشريه على اهم النقاط التي تيسر
قبولنا لوظيفه وما هو الرد
كما نشاهد
حتى ان مستوى الذكاء العاطفي غير المتوقع
من نظام الالي يمكنه مساعده مستخدميه في
الشعر والعلاقات الانسانيه وحتى العاطفيه
وبالمقاييس والتفضيلات
المطلوبه مع كل هذه الامكانيات وصل عدد
مستخدمي تشاد في الايام الخمسه الاولى من
الاعلان عنها قبل عامين الى مليون مستخدم
استغرق منصه نتفليكس اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
فيسبوك عشره اشهر لجمع هذه هذا العدد من
المتابعين وانستجرام نحو خمسه وسبعين يوما
ولذلك
اصبح طفره مقلقه كيف يمكن لالا ان تفهم
المطلوب من خريجيه كليات الحقوق في
الولايات المتحده قبل الممارسه المهنيه او
حتى الانتقال من ادخال نص سؤال الى ادخال
صوره على سبيل المثال كهذه
تجيب على ما يمكن طبخه من هذه المكونات في
الصوره مرحله متقدمه هنا يوفرها الاصدار
رقم اربعه من تشاتشي بيتي الاخير فاين
يكمن السر وكيف وصلت الاله الى هذه
القدرات الاجابه مشاهدينا في اللانجورج
مودرن او نموذج اللغه فمن خلاله انتقلت
القدره الحسابيه الحسابيه للكمبيوتر الى
الكلاميه ما يفعله هو ببساطه التوقع
والاحتمال وهنا التطور يكمن في تقرير هامش
الخطا بحفظه كم من هائل ومغول من
المعلومات في هذا النظام كيف نبدا جمله
مثل عاصمه السعوديه هي سيجيب
بالرياض والعربيه ان تعرف سيجيب تشاتشي
بيتي باكثر لكن هذا ليس كافيا تبقى عمليه
البحث هنا محدوده كونها تتعلق من الاساس
بالسياق وبما يسبق وما يلحق من كلمات
مدخله ومبنيه على التوقعات وهنا تظهر
او الخلايا العصبيه الصناعيه ثوره في عام
2017 في الذكاء الصناعي نعم هنا وصلنا
اذا كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا الخلايا من اهم
اختراعات هذه الخلايا المختلفه كانت خليه
تي التي ترمز الى خليه ترانسفورمرز او
الخليه المتحوله وهي التي
الموجوده في تشاد جي بي تي نهايه اسم
النظام تتميز باعطاء الكلمه المفتاحيه
اهميه التركيز في البحث الذي يتطلع
المستخدم لاخذ اجوبته والنتيجه ثقه
وشميريه وفهم للنص والان للصوره وحتى
مقاطع الفيديو مع الاصدار الاحدث
بينما تحرز الصين تقدما سريعا في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي وروبوتات الدردشه تعمل
الولايات المتحده على تطوير استراتيجيات
جديده لمواجهه زخم تخصص الدوله المزيد من
الاموال للبحث والتطوير في مجال الذكاء
الاصطناعي كما تعمل على زياده شراكاتها مع
المؤسسات الاكاديميه والشركات التكنولوجيه
الرائده للترويج للبحوث الامريكيه على وطن
على ذلك تعمل الولايات المتحده لتقويه
مجموعه المواهب التقنيه لديها من خلال
الاستثمار في مبادرات تعليم العلوم
والتكنولوجيا والهندسه والرياضيات وتشجيع
المهاجرين الموهوبين على البقاء في البلاد
بالاضافه الى تعزيز التعاون الدولي مع دول
مثل كندا والمملكه المتحده لتجميع الموارد
وانشاء جبهه ابحاث اكثر فعاليه في هذا
المجال
واشنطن تستكشف ايضا تدابير التنظيميه
لضمان ان تلعب شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي
الصينيه نفس المعايير الاخلاقيه مثل
نظراتها الامريكيه
هدف الشركات الامريكيه يبقى الحفاظ على
قدرتها التنافسيه في سباق التكنولوجيا
العالمي
للمزيد ينضم الينا من الكويت الدكتور محمد
قاسم استاذ مساعد سابق في كليه الدراسات
التكنولوجيه وعضو مجلس اداره المدرسه
الرقميه اهلا بك اذا دكتور محمد يعني طفره
تولد طفره الان وصلنا الى
يمثل ثوره في عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
اصبح اذكى حتى من ذي قبل كيف سيغير ذلك
حياتنا
طبعا الان شادي بيتي يحل جميع وسائل
الاخبار لان وصل الى مرحله يستطيع فيها ان
يجيب على اختبارات حتى اللي قبل قبل يعني
مجرد ايام لم يستطع حلها واصبح مستواه الى
ثمرين بالمئه
سيغير التعليم سيغير العمل سيغير
الشركات سيغير كل نظام حياتنا على الاطلاق
لا يوجد له مكان محدد يعمل فيه انما سيعمل
في كل حياته وسيكون من ضمن نسيج الطبيعه
اللي نشترك فيها اليوم ضمن النسيج الطبيعه
ام هو مقلق كما حدث في العقود الماضيه مع
تطور يعني مع الثوره الصناعيه في بريطانيا
وفي غيرها من الدول كانت هناك دائما
مناهضه لهذه التكنولوجيا المتطوره
الى اي مدى سيهدد الوظائف تشادشي
طبعا بكل تاكيد كما ذكرتي في المقدمه انه
ليست هناك مكابح على الذكاء الاصطناعي
سيتحرك والا لم يتحرك التنافس الشديد هذا
ستصل بعض الدول الى استخدام
برامج تقنيه مثل هذه الذكاء الاصطناعي
لاستخدامه في السلاح وغيرها لكن بالنسبه
للوظائف بالتحديد كثير من الوظائف مهدده
الان يعني لم نتوقع اصلا ان بعض الوظائف
مثل المحاماه ان تكون على قائمه الوظائف
المهدده بالانقراض كنا نعتقد ان الوظائف
الدنيويه او المكرره هي المهدده ولكن
بمجرد ان خرجتي حتى ثلاثه يعني قبل حتى
اربعه بدات هذه الامور تظهر
لنا ان هناك وظائف محدده يبدو ان ستتاثر
كثيرا في المرحله القادمه ربما الان حتى
المحاماه على سبيل المثال او التعليم او
غيرها ستستغل على اصطناعي لتطوير ذاتها
لكن في المستقبل ان اصبحت هذه التكنولوجيا
اكثر تقدما لا اظن الكثير من الوظائف هذه
سوف تزال تماما وتستبدل باشياء جديده بس
عموما اليوم اذا الشركه لا تستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي اعتبريها شركه ستندثر خلال
سنوات القادمه اذا شركه تستخدمها بالتاكيد
سوف تستفيد منها وتتقدم بشكل سريع
ولكن كيف تعمل هذه الاله على فهم العاطفه
كما ظهر في الكثير من البحوث مع
السؤال ممتاز حاليا بالتاكيد الذكاء
الاصطناعي لا يستشعر هذا العاطفه يعني ليس
لديه الوعي حتى يعرف كيف نحن نتعاطف لكن
هو عنده قاموس ضخم جدا من المعلومات اللي
لها علاقه في العاطفه فهو يفهم الكلب
الكلمات اللي نعطيها له ونخاطبه فيه فيها
ومن هذه يستلهم المشاعر اللي عاده نتخاطب
فيها لكن ان يكون لديه شعور ووعي بهذا
الشيء فهو ابدا ليس كذلك لان من المعروف
انه يعمل على نظام دكتور وضحت الخطوه
للاسف وصلنا الى نهايه حلقتنا سنختم معك
في حلقتنا من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله
انا حنين الشولي وهذه الساعه
[موسيقى]